foreign
[Music]
and today I'm going to be talking about
allocating covid-19 vaccines in West
Africa
so before I get into that I just want to
spend a few minutes talking about my
organization I work with Palladium Group
which is an International Development
organization we work with a lot of usaid
funded projects in West Africa and Latin
America I primarily work on this um
big usaid funded project called Data Phi
where we primarily work on HIV and
covid-19 programs in Latin America and
West Africa
so we do a lot of data science in public
health that involves um something like
this building optimization models to
building anomaly detection models for
data quality assessment to building risk
core models to figure out who should be
who who in the population is at a higher
risk for HIV so that you can optimize
your testing resources
so in uh 2021 we were approached by a
couple of West African countries with a
very interesting problem that there was
an influx of millions of vaccines from
Kovacs gawi World Bank
USA into African countries but suddenly
they found themselves with more than
enough vaccines to meet their needs but
they found themselves very lacking when
it comes to supply chain issues just the
infrastructure around
sending vaccines across the country
vaccinating millions of adults in a
period of less than a year or one and a
half years was a huge problem and we
found with a little bit of research in
talking to our country Partners we found
that a lot of countries ended up wasting
vaccines because they were just not able
to administer those vaccines before
their expiration date
so this was a very interesting problem
very different from what we were seeing
in countries like USA or European
countries
so we thought okay this is a great
opportunity let's build an allocation
model let's build an optimization model
where we'll uh take into consideration a
lot of factors like time to expiration
uh travel uh time between distribution
centers to vaccine sites how many human
uh you how much staff you have available
at vaccine sites to hesitancy and
everything we had a whole model in place
but then uh we faced reality
so this is what the vaccine a
vaccination sites look like look like in
country this is a picture of a mobile
vaccine site from coteva or Ivory Coast
and we found that data was being
collected across different platforms
some sites had tablets some sites had
paper-based data entry
um
this is what vaccine storage at site
looked like
some of the better equipped sites had a
data entry person with a tablet who was
able to enter patient level data into an
app
so essentially we found ourselves in an
extremely low quality data environment
so you know none of the pillars that are
beautiful optimization models could
stand on existed we found that like I
said
um data was being collected across
different platforms there was a lot of
fragmentation across the data collection
chain then we found that the stock data
was being collected and managed in an
Excel based tool there were four
different types of vaccines
there was jnj and cinnofarm and Pfizer
and AstraZeneca there was no data on
Healthcare staff available at site level
so we suddenly found ourselves in a very
um
challenging environment
so
this is where we decided that
we slightly decided to change the final
goal of our work so we were no longer
looking at building an exact
optimization model that should give you
uh you know the exactly correct
um data on how to allocate vaccines we
figured that currently the Ministry of
Health is just using whatever
haphazardly using whatever information
they have at hand most of more often
than not it is just based on what
um what is the usage rate at uh
vaccination site or eligible population
they're not looking at any other factors
so we decided to use some open source
data pull in whatever proprietary data
we could get from the government and
combine all of that to create a vaccine
allocation tool so this is a list of all
sorts of Open Source data that we've
just we pulled into our tool
we pulled in population data from World
pop there were there was data on
Healthcare sites across sub-Saharan
Africa then we were able to use bunch of
our packages to calculate travel time to
calculate catchment area for vaccine
sites and that was that combined with a
lot of country data so even the list of
data sets listed here
um were not available at the start we
had to and we are still working with the
country
um a lot to get these data sets they are
um they started collecting data on
you uh Healthcare stuff available at the
site level after we requested them to
share that data with us we're working
with them on how to collect these data
sets in
a routine and a systemic systematic
format
so then uh this is this was our approach
to creating this vaccine allocation tool
where we would combine a bunch of Open
Source data with country specific data
and create this tool which gives you
some sort of an estimate for how to
allocate vaccines we are no longer
asking the Ministry of Health to look at
this tool as end-all be all for
allocating vaccines they should be
looking at their ground realities and
comparing with the suggestions from this
model and then making their decisions on
how to allocate the tool
so
when it came to where to build this tool
we wanted to and several I think all the
um presenters before me have mentioned
that when you are working in public
public sector you're often working with
extremely low data environment uh cost
is always an issue so you're always
relying on open source tools so we
wanted to build a low-cost easy to use
interactive and
portable app and then of course shiny is
the only thing that came to all our
minds so we built a shiny app and this
is what the landing page looks like it
exists in
it exists in both English and French
right now so the app lets you change the
input language
so that because most of our country
staff speaks French quotable is a French
dominant country none of the nobody on
the data science teams speaks French so
we have an English version for ourselves
so
so this is our shiny app and
you will see that
on some some of the other tabs we still
have text in both English and French
that's for our internal reference this
app has still not been rolled out but um
so
this uh the second tab called stock data
essentially just displays all the stock
data that we processed from the
Ministries Excel based tool you can look
at what types of vaccines are available
their batch number their expiration date
number of doses number of vials
available and we use this information to
uh build the
allocation
model
then we have a distribution Network
which
displays
the distribution Network for Cote bar in
code about the vaccines come to a
National Distribution Center from there
they go to Regional Distribution Center
which from there on they go to District
level distribution center and then from
there they are sent to vaccine sites
we've divided these into separate Maps
because obviously it was very difficult
to view everything in a single map
so
on the
um on the left hand side you can see
this Regional to District level
distribution maps and then on the right
hand side you can see uh them the
connection between the center the
national level Distribution Center to
Regional Distribution Center
then these are the location of all the
wax vaccination sites across the country
so
um in our input data we do have the
entire distribution Network so which
sites are assigned to which districts
and this is a list of all vaccination
sites and users can come in here and
they can select or unselect any
vaccination sites because we often see
that the ministry will roll out during
they'll have periods of vaccine
campaigns where they will roll out 50 to
100 additional backs mobile vaccination
sites so that can be added here and then
when they're done with them they can be
removed from the model
so you can see users can
come in and check or uncheck and then
they can save the list of vaccine sites
once that is done they can go over to
the proposed distribution tab this
allows you the first user input here we
have is number of days because of the
complexity of the model we needed to
ascertain how many days does the
ministry have to allocate these number
of vaccines so they can decide here that
we have these current batches and based
on the expiration date we want to
allocate all of these vaccines in the
next 20 days or 30 days they are the
default we've used is 30 days Days based
on the ministry's feedback and they can
save this information and then run the
model so once
all of this information is saved we
click this button to run the model which
will
produce your proposed distribution Maps
so this takes a few seconds
but this is essentially a linear
optimization model with
um
in with constraints around
expiration date
time to vaccinate
eligible population we will walk through
the list of constraints
in a bit so this is the proposed this is
the distribution map that is generated
by the app you can look at the map and
then
if you
hover over any of the vaccine sites it
will show you the name
the regional Depot and the district
Depot that site is connected to when the
number of vaccines of each type
allocated to That vaccine site so here
we can see that this site has been
allocated only Ceno farm so 720 two
doses of Sino farm and none of the other
ones then we can see here this site has
been allocated 960 doses of Pfizer
so so on and so forth you can click on
any of the site and look at how many
noses have been allocated
to that particular site
then there's the map below where um of
course the above map was a little
difficult to read so you can filter
um this map on whichever District you
want to look at and here we've
selected abobo East and you can zoom in
and look at the number of vaccines
allocated to each of the vaccination
site connected to this District
Distribution Center
so yeah this is basically the model once
this
is done you can users can go over to
results tab where they can view all of
these results in a tabular format they
can see which how many doses of each
type of vaccine has been assigned to
each vaccination site they can download
these results share it with their theme
and make decisions based on this
then we just have a tab for model
documentation
but this is
um
the
shiny app for vaccine allocation tool we
still haven't launched it next month we
are going to have a training session
with our Ministry of Health and their
covid-19
covid-19
team in country and once this is done we
will be
transitioning it off to the team so that
they can update and use this
um tool for making decisions allocation
decisions going forward
so like I said this is essentially a
linear optimization
um
problem where our main focus was our
decision variable was to figure out how
many vaccines should be allocated to
each site
and um
the optimization objective was to
minimize wastage and while maximizing
the number of people vaccinated in the
eligible population and we ran into we
started with a smaller list of
constraints but over time we ran into
um you know as you work with the data
you figure out uh
some additional constraints so it
included that
we had to rank prioritize batches based
on their time to expiration so not only
did we have four different types of
vaccines for each type of vaccine you
could have multiple batches so we had to
make sure that the model starts to
allocate the batches that expire first
before it allocates batches that have
more time to expiration then
um we uh yeah we had to there were a lot
of constraints around expiration date
making sure that it's
um uh delivered and administered before
its expiration date that there are
enough people to administer those
vaccines at the site
so yeah this is um the
um
our vaccine allocation
tool there was a lot of hesitancy from
the ministry initially about using R and
are shiny as a lot of you might know
that normally in public health care
especially in Africa countries tend to
use dhis2 platform so they were
extremely hesitant to you know work with
a new platform a separate one for their
covid-19 vaccination means but once they
saw what we did to bring them on board
was that before we even got any data
from the country we built a mock app we
travel to the country we had a training
uh requirements Gathering Workshop we
showed them the app they were able to
use it and see how useful it can be for
their decision making and that was
essentially all we needed to get them on
board and since then they have been
um extremely active and instrumental in
ensuring that we receive all the data
that we need we have regular meetings
with the Ministry of Health folks and
their covid-19 task force to ensure that
they are abreast with all the changes
that are happening that we are making to
the model
and um we are still figuring out some of
the challenges with uh transitioning
this tool over to the country team like
I said you know they
this is a new tool for them they don't
have our programmers on their team so we
will we're continuing to work with the
ministry
to figure out those challenges
but yeah and
that's where my talk ends I is I would
like to advertise
um this a little bit since I got a
chance that I am hiring a senior
associate in data science ours is a
small but growing theme and we work on
very interesting problems we don't have
huge data sets but we do have uh we do
build very interesting uh models so do
get in touch with me if you have any if
you're interested
great it's like anybody
[Music]